Kill the boy Jon Snow and let the man be born
Welcome back everyone happy New Year George RR
Martin revealed a bunch of the Game of Thrones
sequels and spin-offs the prequel shows have
been canceled some were delayed so we'll break
it all down there is a lot of good news they're
still doing a bunch of the successor shows like
House of the Dragon so of course I'll be doing
videos for all of them just like I did for the
main series like I did for House of the Dragon
they're making season two right now be sure to
subscribe to get everything they'll be filming
House of the Dragon season 2 for a lot of this
year so we'll get a bunch more footage from the
set they've already been talking about blood and
cheese like they're going to introduce them in
the season premiere so it will be every bit as
crazy as you hoped it would be I'll probably do a
separate video this week about season two episode
one or sometime soon with everything that they've
revealed but George R Martin made his typical
end of the year post updating everyone on what's
happening with the billion other Game of Thrones
sequels and prequels they've been making and
developing it was good news and bad news the
bad news wasn't all that bad though he said that
because of all the nonsense with the at&t Warner
Brothers Discovery merger this past year a lot
of their plans for the many many series in the
Game of Thrones universe were either indefinitely
delayed which is basically like Hollywood's way
of saying that they've been canceled but he said
the good news was that some of them were still
continuing to go forward Full Steam ages that
things weren't happening quite as fast as before
because they're so strapped for cash right now if
you haven't been keeping up with the news the real
reason for all this chaos at Warner Brothers is
that they're trying to get three billion dollars
off their debt as quickly as possible which is
why so many different kinds of shows and movies
have been canceled left and right there's been
all kinds of memes and people going crazy all
year they legit have been canceling series that
have finished filming or like ready to go even
full movies that had finished filming an easy
way for them to save 200 million dollars is to
not green light a bunch of Game of Thrones sequel
shows all at the same time so HBO separately who's
controlling all this Game of Thrones stuff just
canceled the series that they thought would be
the least popular because subscribers to them
equals money so whichever ones were likely to
bring in the least subscribers were the ones
that got axed or put on very very long High as
well they try to make them better George R Martin
is involved in developing all them like he's much
more involved than he was in the development of
the original Game of Thrones series he's much
more powerful like he has a much bigger say within
the actual writer's room about what they're doing
and before he made his announcement there were
nine total Game of Thrones sequels and prequels
so there were already a ton of them so the fact
that they canceled a couple of them isn't that
big a deal like they'll be making Game of Thrones
spin-offs until we're 80 90 years old like I'll
be this crusty old man still talking about the
new season of Game of Thrones can you believe
what just happened this week it'll be so much fun
I can't wait to tell my great great grandchildren
about Game of Thrones I'll go down the list of all
them explaining which ones were confirmed to still
be going which ones were just delayed a little
bit longer and which ones were outright canceled
first off is House of the Dragon of course they're
still making it like I literally just talked about
it they're filming season two really soon behind
the scenes the really cool thing about that show
is it actually got way bigger when they started
making it originally it was just going to be like
a regular Dance of the dragon show and run for
four to five seasons and then they'd do something
completely different it would have been like
better call Saul's relationship with Breaking
Bad what HBO did though is essentially they
upgraded their plans for that and now they're
going to use the house of the Dragon title in
that particular showman or Ryan Condal who's
running that with George RR Martin to cover many
different time periods in the Targaryen history
from the Fire and Blood book but they'll treat
it like an anthology series now just covering
different time periods every couple of Seasons
they've specifically referenced aegon's Conquest
the blackfyre Rebellion the tales of Duncan egg
So the plan right now is for house the dragon to
cover the dance of the dragons for three to four
seasons at least maybe five but probably just four
the way they're moving so quickly through the
timeline and when they finish the dance of the
Dragons they'll jump to a different part of
the timeline do aegon's conquest or blackfy
Rebellion with a completely different cast and
they'll treat it like House of the Dragon season
five like just like next season kind of like
American Horror Story like an anthology type of
series rank handle the showrunner said that they
specifically referenced the crown on Netflix as a
show that would jump through time with different
actors playing characters so they're just going
to continue doing that for many different time
periods many different events in the Targaryen
history that's how you get 10 plus seasons of
House the dragon they treat it more like an
anthology the next one they're still making is
the Jon Snow Game of Thrones sequel this is true
basically for any sequel show starring one of the
core main characters from the original series Arya
Stark is another example Maisie Williams is like
well yeah they come up with a good enough idea of
course I'll come back and I'll do an Arya series
after the original show ended there have been talk
of doing an aria series at some point for her
adventures on the western continent like what's
west of Westeros what did she do when she left on
that ship the only thing about the Jon Snow series
they probably just delayed it for a little while
and won't actually start filming it till they
announce producers directors or Supporting Cast so
they're not expecting them to start filming this
year or even next year like they probably don't
want to air multiple Game of Thrones series at the
same time right now if you remember back when at&t
bought Warner Brothers that was their big thing
like we need to have multiple Game of Thrones
series on at the same time I mean they're like
wow that's a whole lot of Game of Thrones because
of all the financial problems that Warner Brothers
has had with this discovery merger they've
had to back off a lot of those plans so it's
probably just like one Game of Thrones series
at a time now and that is House of the Dragon
the next big one is another house the dragon based
Series so Ryan Condell showrunner of the House of
the Dragon said that before he started working on
the series right now with George R Martin he was
actually pitching HBO a Tales of Duncan egg series
since he jumped to House of the Dragon it's been
an enormous success for them they're making like
a billion seasons of it at this point what they'll
probably do is just slot in the tales of Dunk and
egg as one of the events that they cover later on
in the timeline might be a long time before they
actually cover it but they're still probably
planning on doing it within the house the dragon
larger idea the events of Duncan egg follows sir
Duncan the tall who's the ancestor of Brienne of
Tarth and egg the future aegon the fifth king of
Westeros but when he was a boy they referenced him
during the original series egg is Maester Aemon's
younger brother that's how old maester Aemon is
he's he references him when he died maester Aemon
was originally the next person in line within his
family for the Iron Throne after his father passed
away but he wanted to avoid the Bloodshed of the
blackfyre rebellions and the dance of the Dragons
he didn't want the family to turn on itself again
so he took the black giving up his position which
passed to his younger brother the other cool
thing about maester Eamon in egg's backstory
is that there's a little bit of crossover with
the blood Raven who became the three-eyed Raven
they'll probably cover his backstory during a
future season of House of the Dragon when they
cover the blackfyre rebellions there's a sea snake
series about Corliss valerian's nine voyages said
earlier in his life so it would be a much younger
actor playing the character all the artifacts that
they featured around the high tide castle and they
featured them pretty prominently are meant to be
trophies that he took from each of his nine famous
voyages around the world they're mostly taken from
parts of essos that we haven't seen on any of the
series like the original Game of Thrones series
or house the dragon yet they've been talking about
this series like it's a completely different thing
like not part of the larger house the dragon
type of Syria series what they probably done
is just delayed it indefinitely it sounds like
they still plan on making it eventually but not
for a long time there's a princess nymeria in the
10 000 ship series they even teased that they were
planning on doing it during house the Dragon
episode 1. the page that Ranier and Allison
are reading from in that book is renira tears it
out of the book is the story of nymeria in the 10
000 ships later during house the Dragon episode
10 Allison actually sends her the page back is a
sign of their former friendship like I kept this
page the whole time nymeria is meant to be this
really inspirational figure to a lot of women in
Westeros particularly to rhaenyra because she was
a woman of great power who's remembered for doing
very great things originally she was a princess
from the royner people over here in essos they
were pushed out of their ancestral Homeland by
the ancient valerians during the expansion of the
Freehold they retreated with the 10 000 ships to
Westeros Landing in Dorne and conquering the area
the martells descend from her line which is part
of the reason why the martells have hated the
targaryens in the crown for so long they didn't
bend the knee during aegon's Conquest and only
join the other six kingdoms as part of Westeros
much much later in the timeline well after the
events of the dance of the Dragons so like during
House of the Dragon season 1 they referenced
potential war with Dora the threat of war with
Dorne a couple of times that's because Dorne is
currently not part of the realm there was a series
about the Golden Empire set in the distant past
long before the rise of the Valyrian Freehold set
in Yi Ti this country over here in eastern essos
it sounds like it was one of the series that they
delayed indefinitely like effectively canceled
maybe we'll come back in some form in the distant
future there was a series set in flea bottom after
the events of House of the Dragon but before the
main series flea bottom is this area of King's
Landing that we visited several times on the main
series and on House of the Dragon Daemon spends
a lot of his time there around as does aegon II
aemond and Kristen Cole had to spend a bunch of
episode 9 going around the houses of ill repute
in order to find him we also got a peek at one
of aegon II's bastards during that episode too I
believe they canceled this I don't think they're
planning on making a flea bottom series anymore
there was also the infamous blood moon prequel
series that they canceled a long time ago it
was set before the first long night thousands of
thousands of years ago this was the famous pilot
that they spent 30 million dollars filming only
to cancel it after seeing the Finnish version it
wasn't that it was bad or anything like that like
they still made a very good episode of Television
it's just that HBO came up with a stronger idea
that they felt like would earn them more money
ultimately or be more popular which was House of
the Dragon George R Martin also said that when
they were making the blood moon series because it
was set so early in the timeline he'd written so
little amount of material for that point a lot
of the material for the show was brand new lore
that they had to come up with so the show would
have felt very different from what you'd normally
expect from a Game of Thrones type of series as
opposed to house the dragon which is very familiar
in the tone the stuff that it's dealing with the
characters the families there were also a couple
adult animation based Game of Thrones series they
were working on George R Martin said he was really
excited about them but they were treated more
like love death and robots where each episode had
different styles of Animation telling different
stories it sounded like it would have been
really cool but this is also one of the ones that
they've canceled because if you haven't seen the
news Warner Brothers has been canceling stuff left
and right like I said to save money but of all the
stuff they've been canceling the stuff they've
been quickest to cancel has been the animation
mostly because the bean counters are saying that
animation brings in fewer subscribers to things
like HBO Max and HBO in general than regular live
action stuff really good example of this is Warner
Brothers just passed on the new Batman animated
series that Matt Reeves and Bruce Tim were making
they decided not to release a Batman series made
by their new big name live-action Batman director
and Bruce Tim who's the guy who created Batman the
Animated Series one of the best TV shows of all
time not just animated series but best TV shows in
general of all time so Warner Brothers just really
hates animation right now but like I said earlier
in my list like a bunch of those series they're
still planning on making it's just going to take
a little bit longer of course I will do videos
for everything especially as we get more house the
Dragon season 2 footage and all probably do some
more bonus videos this week too post all your
questions your reactions in the comments below
if you have any questions about what's happening
next everyone click here for my brand new house of
the Dragon season 2 teaser video and click here
to listen to Kit Harrington talk about the Game
of Thrones Jon Snow sequel thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and Happy New Year!